hello everyone and welcome to top 10
facts about Magnus Carlsen number 1 in
February 2015 Carl Sandburg Garry
Kasparov's record by clocking devised a
low rating of all-time 2872
in 209 at the age of 19 he became the
youngest world number 1 breaking the
record held by chronic
number two when constant rains for a big
event like the upcoming World
Championships it usually involves
spending two or three weeks in a place
with good weather and the sea he and his
team of advisors and trainers spent most
of the day working on chess but also go
for long swings and play basketball and
football number three
Carlson does not watch many movies
because he does not have the patience to
sit through one and a half or two hours
of screen time he says instead he and
wines by watching TV serials his
favorite design field which he has seen
multiple times number four when Carlson
was 12 his parents took him and his two
sisters out of school for a year sold
their car put their house on rent and
took the entire family on a year-long
round-the-world holiday which combined
chess workshops and chess tournaments
that year of school meant that constant
never really found a taste for
institutionalized education and did not
go to university towards the end of the
year Carlson was paired up to play
against Kasparov in a speech chess
tournament Carson played the Russian
legend to a draw he celebrated by eating
ice cream at McDonald's in 209 five
years after that first meeting Castro
became his coach number five absolute
one basketball fan Carlson is also
perhaps beyond which is clear to his
back modeling assignment he appeared
alongside extra leaf Tyler for the Dutch
designer label G star Rose 2010 campaign
and continues to be their brand
ambassador number six at two years of
age he could sole 50 piece jigsaw
puzzles number seven he blindfolded beat
ten Harvard lawyers simultaneously at
chess number eight Magnus Carlsen is not
just one of the best chess players on
the planet he's also been voted one of
the sexiest men alive music in addition
of the women's magazine cosmopolitan
published a list of the sexiest men of
2013 and amongst the average singers and
a third at other celebrities is the
world number one ranked chess player the
netizen described Carlson as a hobby
number nine Carlson says that if he gets
bored by chess he will try something
else for me
it's about playing as long as I'm
motivated as long as it's fun as long as
it's interesting and as long as that
happens I'm going to continue playing
whether that's doing 30 on 40 or 50
going constant said in an interview with
Business Insider if I quit I would
probably start by studying something
that interests me but I don't know what
maybe if I didn't have talent for chess
I find the talent in something else he
said and number 10 madness is a big
Fisher pan he said for the interview for
CNN if I could choose my opponent to be
anyone in chess history it would
probably be Bobby Fischer at his best
but the precision and energy that he
played with is just unmatched in the
history of chess so Bobby Fischer from
1970 to 1972 if you would like to list
the top 10 facts about any other chess
player just let me know in the comment
section below and if you are interested
when my new video will be released make
sure you subscribe to my channel thanks
for watching everyone and have a great
day
[Music]